is really nice set up by bridges
crossover freezes defender
gets the assist throw down by biambo
he's now in his 10th year in the league
under a minute to go in the quarter
lakers down by three they uh trailed by
as many as nine led by as many as six
kuzma thought about it now he's gonna
have to take it
he was up against it clock was down to
two that's one of those free shots you
have to take it you relax and just go
ahead and shoot
keep an eye on kuzma to see if that cap
is bothering him at all
you know early in the first quarter i
thought he was dragging it a bit
when i say dragging it not really
running freely but he seems to be
playing through it
well here he is throw it down doesn't
look too bad on that did it
other run the one-hand hammer
wow that that was
nars showtime
52-50
[Applause]
yeah it felt okay there didn't
shot is about a second ahead of the game
mcdaniels can't score so what an end to
the quarter for the lakers
kuzma can really cap it off and he
nearly did
[Applause]
wow what a finish to this second quarter
especially back-to-back hoops by coos
first to triple
and then he comes down and gets a return
pass from kcp
and flushes goes right over the top
of the defenders and throws it down
that's really
nice looking play